okay so the timing of our vacation ended
up being perfect because we had this
really funny voicemail a couple weeks
ago where someone sort of sang to me in
the voicemail and I said let's anybody
who's got some music production skills
turn this into like an EDM remix or do a
dubstep remix or a parody or whatever
and they just poured in during the
vacation and I'm gonna play some of them
for you today so this I think a lot of
people are going to like this I know
some people get mad when not everything
is about politics but there's a lot of
different things that we talk about on
the show so I hope you'll enjoy this
let's start with some of these are so
good let me just remind you this is the
voicemail that came in a couple of weeks
ago that is the source audio for much of
what we're about to hear today
take a listen the David Pakman show
it's my favorite show you do more good
than you know the David Pakman show
[Music]
exactly so I asked you know do something
in the EDM style do some kind of dubstep
remix use your creativity they've poured
in okay I've already had to narrow them
down because there were just so many
this is a sampling I do think that there
are actually some contenders here for
becoming our actual new intro theme song
for the podcast radio show and
television show so I'm gonna name these
by number I apologize in advance if
yours didn't make it it's not that I
didn't like it it's that I had to do
some sampling some sub selection because
otherwise this would take all day if you
want to vote on which should be the new
theme song I'm gonna tell you the number
so I'll say this is number one this is
number two
there's only one way to vote and that's
by email using the contact form on our
website it's just it's too hard to comb
through YouTube comments and Twitter
mentions and stuff like that so go to
david pakman.com click on contact say
I'm voting for number one number two
number three whatever you can even just
do it in the subject line and then you
can you know I guess you probably have
to fill in the body to send the message
but you don't have to say much other
than team song I'm voting number one two
three four whatever you can also say by
the way keep the current theme song if
you prefer that we don't have to change
it but to some really good stuff here so
the first submission that I will play is
from art Flores take a listen to this
one
[Music]
sort of downtempo
[Music]
[Music]
okay so I think you get the idea that's
number one okay number one from art
Flores this is option number two from
psycho Nadia I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly take a listen very dark
[Music]
all right so that's number two option
two from psycho Nadia here is number
three this is from Andrew worst ok very
different take a listen
big lead up on this my favorite show
[Music]
- one night I like that okay so that's
number three from Andrew worst all right
this next one is number four extremely
high production value okay this one is
from I don't know if it's pronounced
three lon and the chosen masters or
maybe it's just a lawn with a three I
hope I'm pronouncing it correctly this
has a number of parts that this this is
a extremely cinematic in nature take a
listen to this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay I think you get the idea that is
really something else so that's number
four from three lon or Ilan and the
chosen masters okay number five the only
name I have for this one is sorry for
bat English that I don't know if that's
a handle or what let's take a listen
this is number five now
[Music]
David taxes oh it's my favorite yo-yo
it's my favorite show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so once again that was number five
from sorry for bat English and then
lastly this is number six from Rob
Bennett okay so one through six this is
number six
[Music]
the deepest deepest
[Applause]
the David Pakman show it's my favorite
show
[Music]
yeah so something's sounding a little
bit out of sync in that one but I still
like it and has some great stuff so one
through six alright get in touch via
email from the website david pakman.com
contact us tell me 1 through 6 or keep
the current theme song if you don't know
that we have a theme song because you
just watch clips on YouTube or whatever
and you don't realize that the podcast
radio and TV show have an intro theme
song then I don't know what you should
do maybe don't email me no I mean I
guess just tell me which one of these
you like and if you don't think any of
them are suitable then let me know none
of them are suitable but awesome awesome
stuff those are just six of what must
have been like 20 or so and appreciate
everybody who send them in it sent them
in even if it didn't make the final six
look forward to hearing from people I
guess we'll give it like a week and
maybe early next week I'll announce the
results of the vote by mail